ein Mensch der ein Auto hat und nur zwei
Tote hat der zählt zurzeit als
glückliche Person also ein Freund von
mir 20 Leute von seinen Familie ist
verloren in einem Tag wir hören von
traumatischen Ereignissen das auch
Angehörige die die Leichen ihrer
verstorbenen bewachen und und auch nicht
davon weichen weil sie auch selber
traumatisiert sind die Videos aus dem
Erdbebengebiet in der Türkei und in
Syrien gehen um die Welt sie erreichen
Computer Mobiltelefone und die Herzen
der Menschen in Berlin ist die
Verbundenheit besonders groß in der
Hauptstadt leben viele Türken und Syrer
deren Familien und Freunde in der Heimat
leben wer versucht sie zu erreichen
erlebt bange Stunden
schwierig mit dem Internet also wartest
du das ist sehr anstrengend für Menschen
mit Familien dort du weißt ja nicht wie
die Situation ist es gibt kein Internet
und du rufst immer wieder an niemand
hebt ab aber du hoffst dass jemand am
anderen Ende abnimmt und sagt wir sind
okay
viele wollen und können nicht warten sie
müssen etwas tun humam chehavi und
mudara ich aus Syrien betreiben einen
Club in Berlin die Einnahmen des Abends
sollen den Menschen in ihrer Heimat
zugute kommen
neben der Hilfe einzelner läuft die
internationale Hilfe an während sie im
Erdbebengebiet der Türkei ankommt ist
die Region jenseits der Grenze auch Tage
später von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten
grund dafür ist die komplizierte
machtpolitische Situation im
Bürgerkriegsland Syrien das Wissen darum
lässt Abdul rasack verzweifeln wir
brauchen jetzt spezielles Werkzeug mit
dem man Menschen aus Trümmern befreien
kann im Moment versuchen die Leute mit
dem was sie haben andere auszugraben
Abdul rasag war Journalist bei einem
syrischen Fernsehsender Sekunden bevor
das Haus seiner Familie in sindaris
einstürzte konnten seine Eltern und sein
Bruder sich ins Freie retten seine Hände
zittern wenn er davon erzählt
und ihre Schwester tejan bereiten eine
Gedenkveranstaltung für die Opfer des
Erdbebens vor die
MenschenrechtsaktivistInnen fordern das
Schicksal der Menschen dort nicht weiter
der Machtpolitik zu Opfern im syrischen
Erdbebengebiet ist die humanitäre
Situation seit Beginn des Bürgerkrieges
vom mehr als 10 Jahren katastrophal ob
man türkische Wurzeln hat kurdische
assyrische oder eben arabische der
Schmerz ist international der ist gleich
und natürlich ist für uns insbesondere
die Situation in den kurdisch syrischen
Gebieten deswegen besorgniserregend weil
wir immer wieder hören dass die
Hilfsgüter deutlich ankommen die beiden
stehen ständig in engem Austausch mit
Menschen im Erdbebengebiet während Sie
sich beraten erreicht sie die
Sprachnachricht eines Freundes
ähm gestern haben wir noch rufe gehört
also es geht hat ja noch immer dieses
Prozedere das alle leise sein müssen und
dann ruft man also es gab noch Geräusche
aus den Trümmern das heißt gestern noch
Leute gelebt
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es jetzt heute
noch so ist es sehr gering die
Nachrichten sind kaum zu ertragen
bin einfach auch so entsetzt darüber
dass diese Menschen so schlimmes
erleiden müssen und sich dann noch darum
kümmern müssen was mit den Leichen
passiert und Angst haben dass sie
einfach weggebracht werden also das ist
auch so Höhe würde los ne und das etwas
sehr sehr weh tut einfach und das sind
natürlich eine Doppelrolle die wir
gerade haben einmal als Aktivistin aber
eben auch das ist unsere Heimatregion in
der das passiert ist unsere Erde die
Familie von Arman Keller und bares
beckler kommt aus der türkischen Provinz
hathai bei dem Erdbeben sind
Familienmitglieder von ihnen ums Leben
gekommen wir haben natürlich auch Tote
zu beklagen das ist so einem der Cousin
von meiner Frau und von unseren
Arbeitern mehrere ähm Leute sind auch
gestorben das Restaurant haben sie nach
seiner Heimat benanntei blickt auf eine
mehr als 2000jährige Geschichte zurück
jetzt ist fast alles zerstört
nachdem er von dem Unglück erfahren
hatte haben er und seine Leute sofort
angefangen Sachspenden zusammen und nach
Hatay zu schicken jetzt sammeln sie Geld
wir wollten Geld schicken dass das hat
nicht mal geklappt jetzt machen wir das
natürlich die Leute die Verwandte die
von uns dorthin reisen den geben wir
Geld mit damit sie da das Geld verteile
so viel Geld wie möglich sammeln auch
die Mitarbeiter vom Verein dr Revolution
seit 12 Jahren setzt sich die
Organisation für Demokratie in Syrien
ein dank dieser Arbeit kann sie nun auf
ein Netzwerk von Helfern in der Region
zurückgreifen das Team in Berlin sammelt
Spendengelder von dem Mitarbeiter
notwendige Dinge kaufen der Heimatort
ihrer Kollegin SWAT Assuan liegt in dem
von Rebellen kontrollierten Gebiet
hinter der türkischen Grenze
sie meinte jetzt langsam kommen halt
Sachen rein aber von Händlern die das
halt einfach verkaufen während halt
un-hilfen nicht dort ankommen und die UN
sagt wir können das logistisch nicht
gerade einrichten die türkische
Community in Berlin hat Tonnen an
Sachspenden erreicht am Flughafen
Berlin-Brandenburg sind hunderte von
Helfern mit sortieren und packen
beschäftigt die Spendenbereitschaft ist
riesig ob Türken oder Syrer Harley
bemerkler möchte allen helfen
[Applaus]
wir sind Mensch heute ist der Tag für
menschlich er ist so reagieren kurz nach
dem Erdbeben sind Hilfsorganisationen
mit Sachspenden überhäuft worden weil
der Transport aufwendig und teuer ist
raten sie inzwischen davon ab und bitten
um Geld spenden der Wunsch zu helfen ist
riesig in Berlin gemeinsam anzupacken
auch ein Weg mit dem Schmerz und der
Trauer umzugehen